to indicate if you wish to speak
and i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat
function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
members when speaking and referring to
the agenda papers
please reference a page or paragraph
number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible when invited to speak please
ensure
you turn on your microphone and
video now if i may ask officers taking
part in the meeting to introduce
themselves
starting with mr lee
good afternoon members i'm matthew lee
and i'm lead specialist place here at
morton district council
thank you
thank you and mr johnson now if i may
ask office
thank you chairman my name is michael
johnson i'm lead specialist development
management
thank you welcome um julia sergeant
good afternoon chairman members my name
is julia sergeant
i'm specialist development manager
thank you julia and uh kate please
uh good afternoon members my name is
katie fuller i'm clark
this afternoon's committee thank you
very much
i know are there any other officers
present please good afternoon chairman
good afternoon members tara bird
i'm committee services officer thank you
thank you tara um
kate sir please can you now carry out a
roll call of members to confirm
who is in attendance please thank you
yes chairman members i will call your
name in alphabetical order
please could you indicate if you are
present starting with
counselor ms bill
councillor edwards president kate
thank you uh councillor herd
present councillor lagan
president casey new members
councillor made president
thank you councillor morris
good afternoon everybody good afternoon
uh councillor none
um hello kate yes president thank you
thank you
councillor stilts good afternoon present
kate
thank you good afternoon and councillor
swain
yes present thank you
okay thank you katie and welcome to
all members and of course members of the
public who
are um receiving this uh through live
streaming
uh gender item number two sorry
i think you need to record that i'm
actually listening
yes i do apologize uh counselor bamford
councillor bamford uh is shown could i
ask
actually it's uh sorry my fault there
are there any other members
who have not been mentioned who are
councillor stamp thank you
councillor when you stand welcome to you
uh agenda item number two
is apologies for absence may i have uh
any apologies that you've received
please come
we have not received any apologies
thank you very much agenda night item
number three
um it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 15th of july
2020 and they're
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as
true
and accurate record iso move
if you wish to second that motion please
turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now please
[Music]
thank you councillor none if any member
wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy please use the
chat function
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
okay can you advise if any other member
has indicated a wish to speak i can't
see any online
uh no i've had no um request to speak
that's kind thank you very much so uh
so in order to have these uh accepted uh
we'll have to take the vote
taking each member in alphabetical order
uh please state whether you are for
against or abstain or do you wish to
agree these minutes by ascent
i said yes agree
agreed i said agreed agreed
ah excellent okay thank you very much
um agenda item number four declarations
of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business
on the agenda and having regard to
paragraph six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat
function now to indicate and i will
invite you to speak
i i see one uh so
kate can you advise if any other member
has indicated a wish to speak i i know
i've got councillor morris
yes chairman councillor edwards yes tara
we've got councillor edwards and
councillor morris
perfect thank you very much councillor
morris
thank you chairman just to say i've got
a non-pecuniary interest
my my family owns a holiday caravan on
one of the adjacent parks
um i very often use uh that part of the
sea wall and that i have
been in conversation with a few people
concerning this
um by walking past it thank you can i
sorry
chairman can i also uh say that i would
like to take this opportunity
to second the officer's recommendation
for approval of this thank you
thank you very much and um
councillor edwards
um
yes chairman thank you um i'm aware that
um we have been advised that we no
longer need to declare
an interest if we're a ward member but
i'm a member of hebrews parish council
and i believe we have to or might
have to declare a declaration so i'm
just declaring
that i'm a member of hebridge parish
council
okay that is noted thank you very much
indeed
any other decorations i i think your
hand is still up councillor edwards
thank you very much okay so gender item
number five this is 19
stroke zero one one six four full this
is mill beach public house gold hanger
road
haybridge we now move on to this agenda
item
uh and these are found on pages
11 to 42. please note that a member's
update in relation to this application
has also been perk
circulated prior to the meeting
in a moment i'll call on the off on the
officer to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the chat function within
the meeting
and then i will come to you in turn
please keep your points
clear and succinct uh
ms sergeant could you please present the
report please
thank you chairman
planning permission is sought for the
demolition of the existing and erection
of a replacement public house
with a first floor apartment and change
of use of the land
for the sighting of 12 holiday logical
events
this is the location plan of the
application site which is an almost
rectangular parcel of land
located to the south of goldhanger road
and west of the mill
beach seaside resort to the northeast of
the application site on the opposite
side of gold hangar mode
is the barrow marsh caravan site
this is the existing block plan and the
site
is currently occupied by a two-story
building which was last used as a public
house
it's currently in poor state of repair
there's also single-story outbuilding
and a caravan
located um shown here to the west of the
existing public house
the remainder of the site is
predominantly open and soft landscaped
with grass and some trees
this is the proposed block plan which
shows the positioning of the
replacement public house which is in
approximately the same position as the
existing
this is the illustrative master plan for
the development
shows the replacement public house and
the 12 holiday lodges to the east
which is the area that's currently open
grassland
the site would be accessed from gold
hangar road with the car park along the
western boundary of the site
and some spaces to the front of the
public house there'd be 25 parking
spaces in total for the public house
and one parking space next to each lodge
as
shown here there's also a new permissive
path
running north south sign over here along
the western
boundary which would link gold hanging
road to the seawall
and into the existing public footpath
network
so here's the existing site plan which
shows in better detail where you
footprint at the existing public house
as well as the outbuilding and caravan
and here we have the proposed site plan
which shows the footprint of the public
house
with the outbuilding and caravan removed
and it also shows an
outdoor terraced area so the area that's
hashed grey here
is the internal footprint of the public
house
and this white area around is an
external seating area
so we have existing elevations of the
public house
so these the one at the top shows the
elevation facing the mill beach marine
club to the west and the one at the
bottom is
the elevation facing under gold hanging
road and
it can be seen from this the building's
had several extensions
over the years since it was originally
built
and some more elevations so again top is
facing east
across the grassed area at the bottom is
the
south elevation which currently faces on
to the
seawall so the existing ground floor
plan
and the existing first floor plan which
shows a residential apartment there
currently which was used by the manager
of the public house
and the existing roof plan
so next we come to the proposed
elevations for the replays replacement
sorry replacement public house these
show the elevations facing north towards
goldhanga road
which is the one at the top and west
towards the mill beach marine club
it can be seen that is an external
staircase on this elevation
which would be the access to the first
floor apartment
and the next elevations we have east
across the site and then south
overlooking the estuary
the design of the replacement house or
public house would be
rectangular form building three north
south running gable roof lines as can be
seen here
um it would have a smaller footprint
than existing public house although the
ridgeline would remain the same
includes a high level of fenestration to
make the most of the location of the
site with views across the history
and there's a first floor terrace area
erected around the flat
which would create a park covered
seating area at ground floor level for
the public house
it would be finished in timber boarding
timber windows and doors
and it's proposed to reuse the existing
roof tiles from the
existing public house so we have the
ground floor plan
showing the bar area and indoor as well
as outdoor seating
this dash line here shows the extent of
the terrace
at first floor level so showing that
some of the covers
would have outdoor seating under cover
and then the first floor plan which
shows a two-bedroom apartment which
would be used by the manager of the
public house
or other staff employed by the purple
holiday lodge business
and the roof plant and here we have some
section fans of the public house
again showing the terrace and the
relationship with the building
the sea wall the agent has provided some
illustrative visualizations
to assist in the understanding of the
proposal in terms of the design and the
materials
there's one here from the sea wall and
then one
from within the site we've also got some
indicative images of the holiday lodges
proposed
the lodges would fall within the
statutory definition of a caravan
however a condition has been recommended
to require the lodges to be finished in
timber
or reconstituted wood unless otherwise
agreed and that's condition 8
on the main agenda to ensure that the
appearance would be appropriate and
consistent
with what's been suggested within the
application
here's an aerial view showing the
context of the application site and
its close proximity to existing caravan
sites
some photographs of the site so we have
a view
to the front northern elevation of the
existing public house
from gold hangar road and we'll close
them in the site
and then views at the eastern section of
the site where the holiday lodges are
proposed
you can just make out the adjacent
caravan park
and then there's another caravan park on
the opposite side gold hanging road
some views from along the sea wall so we
have looking looking west here
top and then looking east at the bottom
and then views from along gold hangar
road from the site
the application has been supported by a
number of studies and reports
including a tourism need assessment it's
considered that the tourism needs
assessment has demonstrated that there
is a need and a demand for the holiday
lodge is proposed
furthermore the application site is
located within an area that is
characterized by caravan parks
an addition of 12 holiday lodges would
not result in any advertisement to the
area or countryside location
the site is also relatively well
connected to other holiday sites
and benefits from the sea wall along the
southern boundary which is public
footpath
in terms of the replacement public house
there's no objection to
to this whilst the original structure is
a period property and has some
architectural merit
over the years there's been a lot of
unsympathetic extensions
including a large flat booth extension
to the front of the building
which has harm the visual appearance of
it its replacement of a more efficient
and useful building is therefore
welcomed
and would be in line with policy e3
which seeks the attention of community
physicist facilities
which are public households within the
design of the placement public house is
also considered to be acceptable
and will be finished in timber
weatherboarding which is characteristic
of the area
the application site is located within
flood zone 3
however no objections have been raised
by any consultees on this basis
and it's considered that the submitted
information has demonstrated that
subject to conditions
the development would remain safe for
its lifetime would not increase flood
risk elsewhere
it should be noted that as part of the
mitigation of the site
it would be evacuated upon receipt of a
flood warning however
in a worst case scenario in the event of
anyone remaining on site
the first floor area above the public
house is to act as a safe refuge
the council's emergency planner has
accepted this approach as appropriate
and conditions have been recommended to
that effect
therefore overall it's considered
development would result in
redevelopment of this site in a manner
that would bring it back
into its use as a community facility in
the form of the public house
as well as providing additional holiday
accommodation which would result in a
boost to the local tourism economy
the application is therefore recommended
for people subject to conditions
as detailed in section 8 of the report
thank you chairman
um thank you ms sergeant a very good
presentation thank you very much for
that
so um so members
under the council's public participation
scheme we have
received one submission from the
applicant
in line with the public participation
scheme
i've reviewed the submission and i will
now read out
allocating two minutes for the reading
of
this submission which is in accordance
with the scheme
[Music]
members of the planning committee my
name is mike ringer and i speak to you
today as a local businessman
and owner of the mill beach public house
with the ongoing national decline in pub
business our last
tenant was unable to maintain a viable
business
and left the public house in a very poor
state which has since been vandalized
and now presents an eyesore
in this otherwise attractive tourist
location
this application seeks to rectify that
problem
over the last two years the pub has been
marketed by local pub letting agents
sydney phillips but has failed to
attract a buyer
i have investigated whether it would be
viable to refurbish the pub
to better attract a new tenant however
with the total project cost
estimated at 1.2 million pounds
this greatly exceeds the refurbished
value of the property
it would be impossible to raise the
finance for such a venture
i have therefore looked at the
opportunity to rebuild a modern
new pub with glazed sliding doors and to
allow it to take better advantage of the
estuary views
and passing footfall on the coastal path
the cost of rebuilding this new pub is
still is still
unable to provide an adequate return on
investment
therefore i propose 12 high quality wood
clad
holiday lodges which can
which can both cross subsidize the
rebuilding of the pub
and provide customers to support a
viable pub
business national and local tourism
trends
demonstrates greater demand for higher
quality
holiday accommodation such as holiday
lodges
the local supply of holiday lodges is
limited to a few
lodges on a larger static caravan park
these lack the exclusivity that i can
offer to meet this demand at my site
we have addressed all the matters raised
but with your planning officers and
their consultees
and i therefore respectfully ask for
your support
in helping me to remove the current
eyesore and build a new pub with 12
high quality holiday lodges to provide
an attractive facility for both local
residents
and visiting tourists
so that was uh that was a text sent in
by the
application and i'll now
so the recommendation as set out within
the report
is that it is recommended um
if any member wishes to second that
motion in order that we can debate that
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone
and state your name now i think uh
councillor morris
did second that proposal am i correct
yes please care i've got to second the
motion
um we should be supporting this thank
you very much
uh so if any member uh now want wishes
to make any comments on the report and i
do note that uh
councillor nunn has uh i
i would ask that they indicate that they
wish to
speak please counselor uh german country
edwards as well
please thank you so katie can you advise
me on
on who has asked so far to speak please
uh yes chair we've got uh councillor
edwards
councillor nun councillor swain
and councillor lagan
thank you very much councillor edwards
thank you chairman um as
well a wall councillor although it's in
the east ward
um i know first of all that this was a
member calling
i'm not sure why it was called in as
because the membrane no longer is a
member
um but i just want to make a couple of
notes and an observation
um first of all in regards to the lodges
i don't see any problem at all with the
lodges bearing in mind
as it was previously shown that this is
actually an area where
lodges are and so will not be out of
place
um i also noticed on condition 30th and
31
the issue regarding people evacuating
upstairs number of 200 people in the
event of a flood evacuation
but i do know and this is just an
observation
that the stairs to the upstairs is on
the outside rather than the inside
so um it's just an observation um i'm
not sure if
if that's well i'm sure that's actually
been looked at
in terms of um
having to have an evacuation where
there's a flood area
flooding outside rather than trying to
go upstairs
on the inside it's just an observation
uh but i fully support this this is an
eyesore
in haybridge and having a new facility
like this
would be good for the
hay bridge itself so i would fully
support the
officer's recommendation thank you
um thank you very much um miss sergeant
would you like to come back on that
before i go to any other
offices is there any stairs shown inside
thank you chairman no the the staircase
is external
um that has been looked at and
essentially
the flood event could happen at any time
essentially
generally the site would be evacuated
it'd be a worst case scenario anyone
would be left on site
and with it being an external staircase
it would mean it wouldn't be reliant on
the public house being actually unlocked
and open
for people in the lodges to be able to
access the first floor refuge
so staircase would overcome that issue
okay thank you thank you very much for
that
uh councillor nunn um
thank you chair yes i do want to speak
but i'm happy to give way to
uh any other hamburger
any other hatred members before i do so
i i haven't none others have indicated
their
desire to speak i've got councillor
swain and then councillor
councillor morris has also asked to
speak okay could i just pause you there
then i'll go to councillor morris first
thank you council morris
thank you councillor norman thank you
chair um i'd just like to say that we
really should be supporting this
um i personally spent many a evening
um in my younger days drunk at that
place and every time i walk past it my
heart sinks a little bit because uh
it is a shambles now um it's a derelict
building
it's a bit of an eyesore um it's sad
that the building's got to go
but ultimately we do need to make use of
it because there's not much worse to
look at
than a derelict building this will
obviously bring
employment benefits tourist benefits
local economy benefits
and it should be something that we are
supporting um
hopefully it will be a a nice little hub
a nice little
tourist buzz point um and bring
much needed tourism and uh econom
econo economic ah getting my words in
them um economic um benefits
to the area um so i'd uh ask members to
support
thank you thank you very much um
councillor um counsellor nun
thank you very much chair so um i i
first of all would start off by saying
that i'm not hugely
against this uh development
um but in fact there are aspects of it
that i
particularly like the fact that the
height will not exceed the existing
height
and the fact that the tile is going to
be reused
is certainly to its credit because let's
not forget um
the view of this building is not just
from the road it's from the river as
well
uh so we need to keep that in mind
however it would be remiss of me not to
make a few comments i think
um first of all i don't think any proper
treatments has been given to the history
of this site
both in terms of our local heritage but
also the impact
on the site um because this was a meal
at one time
there is a mill pond which is now filled
in but it's the area where the lodges
are going
so i hope that the developer and
planning department has taken that into
account
also during the 1953 floods this site
was completely
underwater so it is uh prone to
pretty heavy duty flooding you might say
well that was 1953 but you know
tights being tied so that could happen
again
historically this area
is um full of barrows
and mounds uh and also was the sign of
an early saltworks
notwithstanding that mill beach takes
its name from a windmill which was first
directed on the site in 1703
uh and the hotel itself the new bill
bridge hotel
was built in 1894
and i just think it's a great shape that
all of that history
is going to be swept away by this new
development
and i just wish that the developer had
taken that into account a bit more
and at least given some kind of signpost
or nod
to the past but uh no doubt mr lee will
come back on a number of those
points chairman and say that's nothing
at all to do with planning
and it's even rambling on about history
again but uh i just thought i needed to
say those things
okay um counsellor nunn thank you for
that um
it seems like it might be a good idea to
have some kind of
notice board there perhaps with that
with that nod to the past
uh i i know that um
councillor morris wants to come back on
something you said so
with the permission of councillor swain
and lagan could uh
could he just finish could he come back
on that yes sure
absolutely sure thank you answer morris
thank you very much just like council
and none know that um
the last time it flooded was um
before there was see a sea wall defense
there
um and we had the highest tide a few
years ago i can remember
having to go down there and uh check on
my family's caravan and
the highest tide ever recorded uh didn't
flood it
so the sea walls worked very effectively
so uh the 1953 flood
shouldn't happen again thank you
thank you very much for that um i'll go
on now
go on now to councillor swine um
yes thank you chairman there were a
number of um errors i'd like to
um raise points on um
first of all on the specification of the
cottages um
in the flood situation they are anchored
they are firmly tied down not they are
fixed
to the ground as i understand it um
secondly on accommodation it's been
mentioned that there will be
perhaps six people two full-time for
part-time
um as well as the manager
and i'm not sure whether the
accommodation for them or whether it's
not expected that there would be any
other
staff um accommodated on the side
if so i'm not quite sure where they
would be
on that parking this is a pub of course
as well as um
uh the facility for the holiday lodges
um
so um i hope the
officers are satisfied as enough there
for a normal
um pub trade because we cannot have any
parking on the road there
and i would think actually highways need
to look at
making some restrictions ensure that
there isn't parking on the road
i think it'll be very dangerous um
then the main point really concerns
flood risk
um i think as we've covered up um a
general um
tidal flood it would be just a general
disaster for the whole area anyways and
rather than this specific property
but i'm concerned about surface water
um this the whole slight whole
site slopes down towards goldhanga road
so it is absolutely essential that
runoff um
is absolutely minimal um and that the
suds
are adequate to deal with um extreme
rainfall
um i i note that there's not much detail
on that
and that are obviously a condition that
has to satisfy the
flood risk authority and i would
like to know whether we will see the
details of the um
surface water drainage system and
maintenance as referred to in 5.6
um further with regards to surface water
um the application notes that the
a third of the site would be impermeable
um i wonder if that can be reduced by
ensuring that some of the parking or the
park materials used for parking
um is permeable because this would
greatly increase the risk of runoff into
into gold hanger road um and
we need to be reassured that the normal
drainage facilities will cope with
um normal runoff as which were
greenfield
i am this is probably not something for
the planets but for
angular and water but uh i'm amazed that
we
allow surface water um to be
excess surface water to go into the
public combined sewer
and this this sort of um uh action can
only increase the risk of foul
um uh contamination and
foul sewage being pushed out into the um
into the public area i don't know
whether the flood risk
the flood assessment and the suds and so
on can
actually avoid this possibility of of
surface water going into the combined
public
sewer okay
thank you very much indeed uh thank you
very much steve for that
um councillor lagan i have you down next
thank you thank you chair um i just
pulled up my paper here
the the these are really comments and i
echo
um other members and the the officers
excellent report and presentation that
the the public house itself is very much
an eyesore now and i'm
very saddened that it's got into that
condition and i fully understand
the the principle of the developer but
what what concerns me a little bit was
section 5.1.4
because the application site is outside
the defined settlement boundary for
haybridge
obviously the intrinsic beauty of the
countryside
it has been assessed with policies e3 e4
and e5
um it's it's interesting to me that
the the loss of that particularly
vista and where councilman talks about
the mill pond there
and i'm very mindful mr lee that no
one's a view um
that it's it's a bit of a shame that the
whole of the area will be used up for
holiday lodges
where we seem to have a substantial
number
of holiday accommodation that's
available to us in in that area
that's not all used um and also we have
a
a perfectly good travel launch which is
a different type of accommodation i know
but we are getting more accommodations
so my concern is a little bit about
we've got the amount of development
because the pub itself does need
something doing to it
uh without a shadow of a doubt but my
concern is that that number of lodges
really will will cause an additional
burden on on
flood risk etc and and really we we
should be in a position where we we look
about
how do we preserve some of the the
countryside and
the areas that we've got still which are
still open rather than infilling all the
time
so i have a concern that the intrinsic
beauty of the area is going to be lost
although i i think that the thought of
the plan
and the principle of the plan is
actually sound so they're just comments
that they're not criticism they're just
comments
thank you chair thank you very much
um so either uh miss sergeant or
uh mr lee perhaps can you just assist on
uh
a couple of those i have i've noted
those
were you able to come back on any of
those miss sergeant i've got a note of
them if you haven't
do uh do you want me to pick up of
couples julian do you want to pick up
some of the others or
how'd you want to deal with it okay yeah
thank you very much you want to take a
couple matters fine
just a couple of the points uh dominique
once raised by a councillor none um
my understanding at all i'm not quite
constantly on what the point in relation
to
the fact there was a pond there is if
you talk about the structural
requirements that is
not something the planning would take
into account that would be something
that
the applicant would need to ensure is
acceptable and
if there is engineering works needed to
ensure that it is safe and secure that's
his own risk and at his own cost um that
isn't something that the planning system
particularly
takes into account um
not just the history of the building uh
yeah my understanding is it was built we
know it was built sometime between 1874
and 97
um because of the os maps and that i
think it was licensed in 1894.
um so you know the fact that it is a
historic building has been considered
and the
local plan authority is well aware of
that um
we've done an assessment historically on
the application on the site you know and
it
we don't consider the lpa that the
property contains any notable
architectural features of its time
um obviously as sergeant said in the
presentation there have been a number of
extensions additions and alterations
and on balance or i don't think it's
even on balance you know it's a
professional opinion of the lpa that
um the loss of the historic asset on
itself would not
stand up as a defendable reason for
refusal but obviously
certainly that is a subjective opinion
but that is the professional
officer's uh point um in relation to
flooding i thought that was being talked
quite a lot so um
won't be in relation to councillor
nunn's point
um the site isn't a flood risk um
it's a site that if this was permanent
residential accommodation
rather than lodges that is holiday
accommodation i think it's something
that is quite likely to be getting a
different recommendation for um
government advice in relation to holiday
accommodation is slightly
less strict when it comes to flood zones
the idea being that
they occupies these lodges should have
permanent accommodation to relocate to
if and when there is a risk and as
mission said in relation to
the terrorists at the pub there is that
as an emergency full back but
i think that would be to use missions
phrase worst case scenario
to be honest that was exact phrase it
was getting through my head before she
said it
um 5.4 the section 5.4 deals with
parking
um and as the report says the uh
car parking requirement pros for the
uh public house is acceptable and policy
compliant
um in relation to the accommodation i
think
i'm not quite sure what the question was
but my understand is that
there is a flat on site but that would
be for
one family aspect of the employment not
expecting
everybody that works at the lodges and
the public house to live in that one
flat
and members
i think it's an interesting point about
it the building being an eyesore and
that's as a reason alone shouldn't be a
reason just to demolish the buildings
obviously then that could in theory
encourage people to
let buildings degenerate to a state
where
they're no longer seen to be attractive
and therefore separates permission
is acceptable on principle so i think
that should be given limited weight in
the overall
assessment of the application but and i
think office report guides you through
that
thought process um in relation to the
number of lodges and the
impact on the country side um
that person as always is a subjective
opinion um obviously officers consider
that there is no
demonstrable harm or at least not to
such a degree as it wants recent views
or as members will know
i always advise you know every
development has some form of harm but
it's about meeting such a standard it
becomes
so onerous or so problematic that it
crosses the threshold to be a reason for
refusal
the officer's recommendation is that
that isn't the case in this but
obviously a area of countryside in
policy terms will become
more developed in the fact that there
will be lodges on site therefore that
is a change um and that transit is a
subjective opinion but that's up to
members as decision makers to come to
i don't know if julie if you've got
anything you'll know to any other points
or some of the ones i've already said
right oh sorry uh yeah miss sergeant
um like i said i don't think anything
particularly other than suds was the
other issue that was raised i believe
um just to confirm that conditions are
recommended that we would have full
details of the suds
along with the maintenance and logs of
the maintenance and that would be sent
to us
to be agreed in consultation with the
local flood authority
right okay uh the other thing that i've
got here is about the
um the spec on the uh on the lodges
themselves that they are
securely anchored in the event of any
flood do we have any details on that
confirm that is the condition council
heard you
thank you very much and uh i think
council
swain you just wanted to come back on
the parking
um yes a couple of points bearing in
mind this is a pub the parking has to
allow
for commercial vehicles as well uh in
the parking spaces
and secondly can we not put in a
condition about permeability of the
parking areas
i think you're still muted sorry sorry
chairman um
that it
obviously the there's a condition
requirement in relation to
discharge conditions and about
such as foul and flooding and suds and
everything and
those will come forward with a suite of
recommendations that should ensure that
there is no harm
that may well include permeable
materials for the car parking
um i'm in theory
clearly we can impose a condition but
there is if they would come forward with
a different suite that still met the
requirement it would be difficult to say
why we
had to say it had to be permeable okay
that makes sense but i think
uh sorry not councillor johnson mr
johnson wants to
expand on that point thanks yes well mr
johnson
yeah just briefly just to say that
condition 23 does cover that matter in
its entirety
it's quite detailed it talks about no
development works above ground level
until detailed surface water drainage
scheme for the site based on the
sustainable drainage
principles and assessment of the
hydrological et cetera et cetera
i mean does this does cover in its
entirety the whole of the site
and an assessment that the uh
permeability of the site is infiltration
rate
as opposed to any surface water
collection
um is suitably assessed and mitigated
so in my view with um i have to admit my
uh
bit of understanding of hydrological
issues on these sites
that is suitable and gives us a
safeguard for the details to be
submitted and assessed as appropriate
thank you chairman thank you very much
mr johnson
um katie can you tell me it has any
other members
uh indicated that they wish to speak
uh yes councillor shawnee councillor
seancy
coming chairman uh thank you chairman um
thank you katie
um yes i too am very pleased that the um
existing tiles are going to be used on
this new pub i think that's great and i
think more use of this sort of thing
you know should be carried out
i would like to know what the building
west of the designated area
is that that wasn't pointed out when
katie gave her
um a demonstration um
i'm also very pleased that um a register
is going to be kept here i mean i don't
know if this
is the um the norm on the sort of
caravan parks
and in general um but i'm very pleased
at that
so that you know the 28-day
thing can be adhered to um and and and i
hope someone will um you know
want to sort of look at that at regular
intervals i think that was mentioned in
the text somewhere
i like the design i also like the fact
that there are bi-fold doors
on the ground floor um terrace
i think that's a nice um innovation
and of course um it wouldn't be me
speaking without talking about ecology
um and so i refer to 5.7.20
um it's at the end of the paragraph
um and it's and it talks about bird
or bat boxes or creation of a wildlife
area
i would rather like to know why it can't
be all three
because bats can't necessarily use bird
boxes
and birds can't necessarily use bat
boxes because the
apertures are a different shape um and
and i think a wildlife area here
somewhere
um to to sort of mitigate um for the
lodges um would be a great idea
um and of course um leaving the trees
and hedges protected
i'm also in favor of um and of course
native planting so there's a couple of
questions in there
um but just some comments as well thank
you chairman
thank you council sean see who would
like to
respond to those officer wise
if i can assist chairman the start of
that the
property to the west of the site is the
mill beach marine club
that wasn't highlighted during the
presentation thank you
in terms of the ecology the ecology
report submitted we have a bat survey as
well as a phase one ecological report
and they recommend and there's a
condition
requiring the recommendations to carry
forward into the development
which includes bat boxes and bird boxes
within the development site
and there is a soft landscaping
condition requiring
full details of soft landscaping
it could be incorporated into that
condition if members wished
that the details to include some native
species and wildlife friendly planting
that could be incorporated into that
condition yes
well i personally would like that um i
can't speak for other people
but i'm glad that you say that it's bird
boxes and
bat boxes so maybe the um the text needs
to be just
brought up to date thank you so much and
thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed um any other
members katie indicated they wish to
speak
uh no chairman we've got no more members
thank you well i'm satisfied all members
who wish to speak have done so
so i propose that we move uh
to the vote so the officer's
recommendation
is that this is um
agreed so you please say
whether it is either you are either for
the recommendation
or against it um katie can you
now please take the vote thank you
members i will take your names in
alphabetical order please could you
indicate whether you are for
against or abstain could i just
uh stop you there could we just uh
confirm
that that is uh with the amendments
referred to um by councillor dornacy
with the amendments
thank you carry on amendments um
so councillor edwards
four
thank you councillor herd
uh yes i'm fullness
against please katie
councillor mays
four councillor stilts
four thank you and councillor swain
thank you that is eight four one against
and one abstention
thank you very much uh for that kate
um so that is agreed
agenda item number six is any other
items of business that the chairman
of the committee decides are urgent i
have none
so i'll move on to agenda item seven
which is the closure of the meeting
members i thank you for your
contributions this afternoon
and i will draw the meeting to a close
at 13
50. thank you to any members of the
public
who are listening in and the meeting is
now
closed